Auf der sonnen aufnahme der us weltraumbehörde nasa ist eine schwarze fläche
Zu erkennen die sich nach unten hin ausbreiten in wirklichkeit aber steckt ein
gigantisches loch in der oberen atmosphäre
Dahinter und es schießt einen partikel strahl in richtung unserer erde dieses kommunale loch ist nicht nur mega spannend sondern auch ziemlich
beunruhigen denn es entstehen immer mehr dieser löcher
Und sie bedrohen die erde was genau steckt dahinter und wie gefährlich können sie uns wirklich werden die antworten jetzt bei pixum science fiction herzlich
willkommen
Ja ihr habt euch dieses thema bei whatsapp gewünscht und bekommt jetzt alle facts zu den sogenannten
koronalen löchern die für uns hier auf der erde eine
Erhebliche gefahr darstellen wenn er übrigens auch auf dabei sein wollt und vor allen anderen meine videos sehen wollt dann
Bleibt bis zum ende des videos dran da gibt es die entsprechenden infos also, so konkret geht es um so genannte
koronare löcher auch wenn sie ziemlich dunkel aussehen sie sind es eigentlich nicht denn diese löcher erscheinen
So dunkel weil ihre fläche kühler und weniger dicht ist als die der restlichen sonne und kommunale löcher sind gar nicht
So selten es handelt sich also um stellen mit einer niedrigen dichte
Im magnetfeld hier entweicht plasma also die sonnenwinde mit
höchstgeschwindigkeiten und zwar deutlich schneller als normal ins all sie werden zu wahren sonnensturm in einer mitteilung des
Space weather prediction center das heißt es eine offene
magnetfeldlinien struktur sorgt dafür dass sonnenwinde leichter ins all gelangen können was zu strömen von sehr schnellen winden führt
demnach können sich forscher immer und überall auf der sonne entwickeln doch besonders verbreitet und stabil sind sie am
solaren nord und südpol sie sind langlebiger als sonnenflecken und überleben oft einige monate ein
beeindruckendes kommunales loch hat die nasa
Im juli vergangenen jahres entdeckt es sendete partikel ströme richtung erde und diese sonnenwinde beziehungsweise das waren schon
Sonnenstürme erschienen dann als kräftige polarlichter, am himmel. Im süden der usa denn wenn die elektrisch
Also, im süden der usa denn wenn die elektrisch geladenen teilchen des sonnenwindes in die. Nähe der erde kommen werden sie vom erdmagnetfeld
abgelenkt zu den polen sobald sie mit luftteilchen
zusammenstoßen ionisieren sie in einer
Höhe von bis zu vier kilometern prallen sie auf die atome der lufthülle und umso stärker sie sind umso weiter
Im süden kann man sie sehen die so betroffenen teilchen werden dabei eben zum leuchten angeregt ein echt tolles
naturschauspiel doch krone löcher sind auch gefährlich für die zivilisation und sie werden immer mehr und damit steigt die gefahr
forschungsteams weltweit gehen davon aus dass es nämlich in der nächsten zeit weniger sonnenflecken und sonnen geben wird dann aber nehmen die
kommunalen löcher zu und beschleunigen die weniger wenigen sonnenwinde zu eben den gefürchteten
sonnenstürmen und die sind dann gefährlich beziehungsweise noch gefährlicher forschungsteams wollen deswegen unbedingt mehr über diese gigantischen löcher
erfahren denn die starken sonnenstürme stören die ionosphäre massiv
so dass sich funkwellen beispielsweise nicht mehr ausbreiten können vor allem kurz und ultrakurz wellen sind betroffen dort findet vor allem der amateur und
Mobilfunk stadt die kommunikation wird dort unterbrochen auch
gps kann betroffen seien dann fallen die navigationssysteme aus oder werden zumindest
erheblich gestört generell können satelliten dann gestört werden und damit unser weltweites
kommunikationsnetz und zudem können solche sonnenstürme das strom- und
Telekommunikationsnetz erheblich beeinflussen und zum erliegen bringen und wir haben hier ja darüber berichtet es kann zu einer absoluten katastrophe
werden ein vorgeschmack gab es 1989 in kanada
als sechs millionen menschen bei minus 15 grad stunden lang ohne strom und
fernwärme ausharren mussten die schäden für die wirtschaft und infrastruktur
können verheerend sein und jetzt steigen wohl die chancen für eine solche katastrophe
wenn er als erstes neues zu diesem thema und zu allen anderen themen erfahren wollt dann meldet euch hierbei whatsapp an
Dann erfahrt ihr vor allen anderen vom neuesten video das ist garantiert
Ihr könnt dort direkt in der redaktion von pixum mitmachen und themen vorschlagen oder fragen zu videos stellen
Der direkte draht zu mir einfach hier draufklicken und natürlich nicht das aber mit der genau
Vergessen hier geht es weiter mit und dafür draufklicken super sonnenstürme treffen
unausweichlich die erde ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran